the jurgen experience hip flexors
that's that's a muscle that so few
people work out and there's this guy
that i follow on instagram
that's become very popular jamie
actually turned me on to him that needs
over toes guy
i saw him with mark mark bell yeah he
was training with mark bell but i i
started implementing a lot of what he
does
in my uh training routine and i actually
got one of those monkey feet
things if you don't know what that is
it's a thing you strap onto your shoe
and you can attach a dumbbell to it so
you lift so like in you know for
like hip flexors to get them strong it's
kind of hard to do but
if you want to be a strong runner or if
you want to throw hard knees
like that's really where the muscle
comes from if you think about
like throwing a hard knee a lot of that
is hit and it also with kicks
if you think about roundhouse kicks like
i've
you know been kicking since i was a
little kid so i've got pretty decent
hip flexor muscles but i don't do an
exercise to work them
other than this stuff like and i started
maybe lunges i guess work them a little
bit but
using this monkey foot thing you you can
actually like
lift weights with your hip flexors as
you're lifting your knee up
and that's all that muscle yeah see if
you find uh
like a video of him doing it but this
guy has some really
interesting perspective on a really
interesting perspective on strengthening
all the muscles around your knee
and he calls it knee over toes guy
because traditionally
if you thought if you talk to someone
they say hey don't ever have your knee
over your toes because it puts a lot of
pressure on your knee it's bad for your
knee
and his idea is no build up to where you
can have your knee over your toes
easily and if you look at his instagram
he does a lot of like crazy [ __ ]
like where he jumps and lands with knees
over toes and goes
all the way down to the ground and then
can spring back up like this [ __ ]
and this is a guy's had like multiple
leg surgeries
and so look how he lands and he does
a lot his his instagram it's knees over
toes guy
is his instagram but he's definitely got
that
monkey foot thing in there somewhere
jamie see if you i found he's doing
the tib thing which is go scroll up i'm
sorry
that's good too but scroll up to that
one he's leaning back right there
yeah watch this this is a crazy strength
in his legs look
he goes all the way back which is hard
to do already and then pops all the way
forward yep
that's [ __ ] hard to do man yeah and
that is
all those muscles that we're talking
about here that's like hamstrings though
a lot of that is hamstrings too i think
yeah because yeah because we'll do yeah
we'll do a similar thing i obviously
can't do it as good as that guy but uh
yeah hamstrings glutes bro the glutes
are super important like uh
and you see that pose that he's got in
the middle there jamie with the yeah
that one with the arrow
so that's showing like the opt what
happened there
that's showing the optimal position to
strengthen
like to have that sort of uh what do
they call a split squat
where you have that crazy angle where
your knee is hanging way over your toes
and obviously you build up to it slowly
like he's got miriam nakamoto
do you know who she is yeah multiple
time world kickboxing champion world
muay thai champion my friend miriam
shout out to miriam
um she's a beast and she has a pretty
significant knee injury that she's
trying to
recover from and she got a bunch of stem
cells and [ __ ] shot in there
but she's now doing a lot of this guy's
program to strengthen all the muscles
around it but see how he's
into doing a lot of stuff that puts you
in that position and let me the dude can
[ __ ]
do some crazy [ __ ] athletically but he
he also uses all these examples
of different athletes that have
incredible explosive power with their
legs and
they use these uh these kind of
exercises and they
they're strong in these positions
so he shows a split squat which is
really hard to do man
it's really hard to get down like that
with that knee hanging way out over your
toes and get all the way down so your
back knee
touches the ground and then pull
yourself back up but
it's true he calls it dense strength and
he's just
you're strengthening all your tendons
and all the muscles that stabilize the
knee
and put the knee in a good position and
for kicking things man
and and in for grappling i i think i
think a lot of guys could benefit from
it look how flexible the [ __ ] dude is
look at that picture right there
and like he does a lot of stuff on slant
boards
if you go to that one the video that we
were just on jamie of him doing a full
split
yeah that one like so he does a lot of
stuff on slant boards
where so he'll have like a like it's
like a a slant board which is good for
stretching your calves out and i started
doing this because of him too
and drop all the way down with a barbell
and go all the way down to the floor and
it's just tremendous hamstring stretch
but also
strengthening and you see the kind of
flexibility that this guy has because of
it i mean he can go all if you can go
scoot that thing all the way up the dude
can go all the way down to a full split
and look at that he's doing a zercher uh
squat grip like where you put it in the
crux of your elbow
with weights
i don't know why he's showing someone
getting slammed into a triangle
i guess i don't know i'd have to listen
to him
but a lot of great exercises he could
find that monkey foot thing he's got
that in there
somewhere i thought i've definitely seen
on his page but the video might not be
up or it's been somewhere else he's just
the only thing i could find was that
tibia thing which is a very close
thing too but yeah it's a different
that's a different thing but that's
pretty dope
too that's a bar where you put your feet
into it and you put plates on the end of
it and it works those muscles on the
tibia
and you know you just flex the foot up
and down so it's like there's all these
different ways you can strengthen
these muscle groups that you don't fit
like there's no direct way to strengthen
them like individually
that you think of and you think of doing
squats you know you're strengthening
them
sort of but you know they're just kind
of coming along for the ride and getting
stronger
whereas this is iceland that's it that's
the monkey feet thing dang those are
crazy
it's dope dude it's really dope i love
it because what i'll do is uh
i'll like hold on to uh like a chin up
bar like this
and then i'll just do these [ __ ] leg
lifts with my
and you could do leg curls with it you
can do leg lifts
but i feel like for a guy like you who
already has a
[ __ ] nasty flying knee that would
make your knee even
scarier catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience